four golden globes does this turn you on  when you get these awards or unit you  don't you don't care you and arousal  every are you around right now what I  wanna that's really what is going on  with these awards does that matter to  Claire Danes are you seem like you're  above old well I mean the nice thing  about winning awards is that you don't  have to win them again anymore you're  kind of like you've been validated it's  okay is the cool thing to take the  awards and put them like in your  bathroom in other words you don't want  to display them to proudly because then  you're a tool so what do we do I put  them in the office and when you'd have  me over for dinner you would say oh by  the way what did you wait let's take a  tour now you wouldn't tell me that was  your Emmy you'd wait for me to notice it  is that the move I that's the move  marker I'm telling you you're smart  that's my move